dems don't care that's the focus of
tonight's angle
it almost seems vindictive at this point
now i'm talking about what the party in
power is inflicting on the united states
runaway inflation devastating family
budgets now
crime waves terrorizing our cities
the fentanyl explosion killing thousands
of americans every month
millions of illegal aliens brazenly
walking across the border and our own
homeless population is exploding
how can this be happening in america
we keep asking night after night how low
can president biden go in the polls
before his team or schumer or pelosi
admit it's time for a course correction
a political party that's actually
interested in success and results you
know that whole making life better for
the average person thing
would know by now that it was time for a
change
but apparently that time still hasn't
come
instead they stick with the same
anti-growth pro-crime policies that have
driven biden to a staggering 33 approval
in the latest quinnipiac poll
and i guess they think that they can
turn this around by i don't know
appearing to feel your pain
we understand some realities happening
right now i grew up in a family
not a joke where if the price of a
gallon of gasoline went up it was a
conversation at our kitchen table it
mattered he understands he understands
how this impacts people's pocketbooks
and it creates uncertainty in their
lives the sad truth is the party of 2022
is not the party of bill clinton anymore
it's the party of black lives matter
climate crazies and trans activists
so how exactly does joe manchin even fit
inside this twisted tent
they seem to be engaged in a brazen act
of self-sabotage
the democrats are extending mass
mandates when americans say it's time to
move on from covet
democrats are turning the border into an
open market for the cartels
of course they're using the doj for
vindictive political crusades and
they're threatening the states that are
actually protecting girls sports it's
insane
and pelosi's house that's not even
requiring people to show up to vote
and schumer over in the senate
apparently thinks it's fine if one of
california's senators is just unable to
perform regular duties more on that
disaster later in the show
and then biden he just throws more money
at student loan forgiveness driving
inflation up even more
and the only thing they change is their
messaging
the vast number of american people
believe that the main reason for their
increase in prices and at the pump is in
fact
price gouging there is overwhelming
support
80 percent of americans for a windfall
profits tax we cannot tolerate in any
industry price price gouging i'm doing
everything within my power by executive
orders to bring down the price and
address the putin price site
okay gouging putin price second none of
it works even nbc admitted it
in reality inflation has been soaring
above five percent for nearly a year and
our latest nbc news poll shows just six
percent of americans blame rising prices
on the russian invasion of ukraine 38
percent blame president biden and his
policies the beltway media that did
everything in its power to take down
trump and boost biden
is obviously now very worried
this all begs the question
when will pelosi hoyer and schumer
trudge up to 1600 pennsylvania avenue to
tell biden he needs an immediate policy
and staff shakeup
why does ron claim the chief of staff
still have his job
how about secretary of the treasury
janet yellen
i see important transitory influences at
work and i don't anticipate that it will
be permanent we see inflation
expectations by most measures and by
most measures see those expectations as
being well anchored
i wouldn't hire her to collect change at
a toll booth we need a treasury
secretary who knows basic economics
and what about all those democrat mega
donors are they happy with things the
way they're going now or are they just
happy colluding to censor speech
if they are well they just don't love
america the way the rest of us do
the only conclusion that the angle can
draw at this point is that the democrats
and their various constituencies out
there
just don't care about any of us
and they certainly aren't interested in
compromise even if it means getting
shellacked in november which is coming
and they called trump supporters
fanatics
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else